q
merci merci d'avoir choisi le milieu
d'un mois
[Musique]
la dernière émission de l'année 2019 et
probablement la 20e édition de la saison
2019 2020
j'ai pas content et j'ai pas fait le
camp n'en est pas loin alors ici en
studio c'est facile à compter et à trois
personnes dans deux collègues qui la
section française de radio-canada et
vinciane bonjour à vous bon allez sans
talent et la wii maryse job elle a alors
j'ai un peu de difficulté à vous nommer
parce que vous êtes dans un ordre qui
n'est pas habituel vous êtes battus
maryse pour la pour la place
non je me suis dit que l'alternance
était toujours intéressé seraient
effectivement dans toutes les choses
surtout avec un est question d'hommes
femmes je pense que c'est idéal
voilà c'est mon commentaire par
aujourd'hui assez peu avancé
alors j'ai quelque chose de nouveau pour
aujourd'hui j'ai attendu la fin de
l'année pour lancer un nouveau concept
non mais on on essaie de le découvrir et
nous peut-être peut-être qu'on va le
faire ce serait super agréable de le
faire dans cette émission pré noël mais
c'est pas tout à fait ça mais à chaque
semaine ce sera à tour de rôle
alternance vous aurez la responsabilité
du segment aujourd'hui je lance la faire
donc c'est moi qui est responsable les
prochaines éditions ce sera toujours
vous maintenant entend cette fois ci
bien noté il faut innover
ça s'appelle ma découverte de la semaine
oh mais faire sa place je pense pas
qu'on va faire une affaire toutes les
semaines mais j'ai découvert ça sur le
site web de radio-canada international
je sais pas si j'avais fait la même
découverte on va regarder la vidéo
numéro j'ai noté ce à 0 pour commencer
l'émission ça part bien une émission
zéro vidéo 0 voilà est ce assez
c'est magic world la semaine parce que
je sais la page web principal de
radio-canada et raciales vous voyez
c'est la page d'accueil oui oui c'est
vrai que le cyber vous avez vu où elle
cherche les mêmes que celles auxquelles
j'ai moi j'ai pour la première fois j'ai
vu ça cette semaine donc on s'abonne on
peut s'abonner dans toutes les langues
que l'on veut enfin nous en fait dans
les cinq langues dans les 5 lundi
moi j'ai coché camp français parce que
l'anglais je comprends rien franche l'an
dernier qui comprend rien
vous allez recevoir un message de
confirmation je suis très content je
suis pas à donner aux cyber journal
je viens de le faire cette semaine donc
on fait il ya plusieurs confirmations
qui sont envoyées d'abord deux sur le
site web
je trouve ça un peu abusif ensuite une
autre sur mon courriel j'allais voir
éventuellement et voilà mon premier oui
je vous reconnais oui c'est la fondation
qui s'y trouvent a dit lundi me mom
lundi au vendredi on publie ça tous les
jours en fin de journée on en voit ça à
tous ceux qui nous qui marraine de
savoir de quoi on a parlé mon produit
neuf sujets par jour
et voilà donc les neuf juges je pense
que c'était mardi ou mercredi les jours
par seulement habitation qu'il y avait
beaucoup de rouge sur la page cette
journée là oui ça ça faisait des sujets
qui ont été consultés déjà c'est fait
non mais les gilets rouges et des
drapeaux bougies les temps des fêtes
rouge
moi je voyais juste l'été la titraille
aussi angliche bon mais voilà voilà
et puis là aussi il ya autre chose oui
vous allez en bas de page et continuer
mois à visiter le site pas je me suis
dit que dans sa jv pas souvent et
j'arrive sur pour aller connecter sur la
baladodiffusion de radio canada
international s'imposer aux balades au
tac que l'on voit lui chaque jour dont
une version sonore uniquement de
nouveaux reportages où nos entreprises
et des nouvelles par rapport à la balado
j'ai quitté là je veux pas voulu aller
plus loin j'ai eu peur parce que en
moins de janvier
oui mois de janvier on va annoncer
quelque chose de tout à fait remarquable
pour ce qui est des balados un résultat
national jose padilla mois de janvier ça
pourrait être le mois de février on va
attendre que le patron se décide
ok on est prêt mais quand il va être
prêt lui on va annoncer ça d'accord
quelque chose de gros qui s'en vient et
c'est très important pour nous au sujet
du cyber magazine ça fonctionne
extrêmement bien on nous dit que le taux
de clic d'ouverture est supérieur à
l'industrie dans le domaine des
télécommunications a fait de très loin
oh oui oui de très très long mais c'est
bien tape dans le dos ouais gros sous
alors voilà pour la ce que j'ai ma
découverte cette semaine je vous avais
découvert vous fait les amener à
l'émission de getafe en europe
on placera ça en fin d'émission
maintenant
premier jeu de la grosse boule cette
semaine on a aussi via trois jeux par
émission et à symbole à perdre la part
de nos collègues et en général ils
perdent tout leur boule rassurez vous
les questions sont assez faciles alors
aussi la première question on l'a fait
chez les grands et n'ont pas non non non
non non dans la question
pas tout de suite ok parce que la
question est liée à notre sujet de ce
sujet la semaine ok on aurait vendu la
mèche sans savoir exactement je pense
que maryse à la petite idée du sujet de
la semaine
alors elle est disqualifiée vidéo numéro
1 5 images deviner le sujet cette
semaine c'est pas facile on va regarder
c'est dans les nuances c'est qu'il
adviendra votre secours si j'aime la
remercie on s'entraîne vidéo et on a
besoin de solidarité
ouais petite pause on a peur oui mais
voilà donc c'est pas facile c'est dans
les nuances à ces noëls que 71 des
femmes et enfin que ça serait joli comme
si snc lavalin way est possible si ces
ateliers c'est un peu lié à 10 mois pas
que le père noël était dans les produits
pas encore bomba latina j'avais pas
encore devenu le sujet de l'émission
aujourd'hui eu procès éviter pour snc
lavalin nom a alors on va voir ce qu'on
dit c'est ça vous êtes en inde
et là vous avez aimé le polder le vol
des données
les nouvelles tendances à l'heure
d'affronter paco téléphonique ok j'ai vu
il y avait téléphone y avait grc enquête
et l'effort je les repas sain je vous
remonte les images vous montrez que vous
auriez dû tout de suite ces appels
indésirables qui nous viennent de
l'ouest par un succès à l'étranger que
maintenant à cause de toutes les
informations qu'on fait passer par le
téléphone
on est très sensible au volet dernier we
pray for d'entités les réformes c'est ça
les formes se multiplient accor terrible
marée mais aujourd'hui est davantage
question des sollicitations
téléphoniques
national hockey de toutes les nouvelles
manifestations de la fraude de la phrase
ya un format ticket le téléphone
d'accord quand on pourrait tout chose
dans une atteinte si vous le voulez
directement là mais je pense qu'on y
fera sûrement allusion voici la première
question de lagonda bull on rappelle
qu'il y a un effet de lumière et c'est
l'émission c'est la première question
plusieurs ont été victimes au canada
récemment d'une fraude particulière de
quel numéro de téléphone les fraudeurs
se servent est il pour faire leur appel
est-ce que c'était à l'office de la
protection du consommateur du québec
est-ce que c'était bon le service
canadien du renseignement de la sécurité
est-ce que c'était ses loto-québec et
vous allez gagner un million ou est-ce
que c était d aucune de ces réponses
aucune de ces réponses mais je vais avec
la même réponse aucune de ces réformes
auraient donc aucune de ces réponses la
même réponse soit ok on va afficher la
bonnerie c'était davantage les appels
internationaux si j'ai mon tronc enfin
peut-être pas qu'ils venaient le moins
vous êtes dans le monde on affiche la
bonne réponse cinq petites étoiles vont
apparaître aux côtés de la bonne réponse
et voilà c'est fait
le numéro qu'on avait utilisé du côté
des fraudeurs du centre antifraude du
canada pour les gens des crochets
téléphone c'était le numéro de téléphone
du centre antifraude du canada préfère
lui falloir du front autour de la tête
m'ont dit c'est ça alors ok alors on a
décidé nous d'aller aux nouvelles les de
parler au centre antifraude du canada
qui fait plusieurs relances plusieurs
messages est ainsi parce que mal à
arriver à la proche de l'automne de noël
prévenir les canadiens faites bien
attention il devient de plus en plus
subtil c'est tout à fait et on pourra
peut-être parler de problèmes qui font
preuve d'ingéniosité
voilà alors nous avons au bout du fil
skype le sergent guy paul larocque du
centre antifraude du canada bonjour
sergent je voulais vous remercier
d'abord et faire mettre la table en
disant que nous vous remercie infiniment
pour tous les efforts que déploie y est
vous et votre équipe cette semaine pour
essayer d'être là sur skype puisque
skype pour votre organisation c'est un
outil potentiellement problématique
je peux aussi vous voulez rentrer dans
les détails mais il ya c'est pas
autorisé à installer dans votre temps
votre dans vos services et au
gouvernement
très souvent on dit non pas de skype et
s'il vous plaît que les problèmes se
fasse et tous les logiciels qu'il
installe sur la plate forme de notre
département sécurité donc à ce moment-là
partir de mai pose pas au travail pour
protéger l'intégrité de notre travail
installer des applications externes peut
être quand même assez difficile d'où il
a fallu que je coure trouver un autre
d'un travail qui était libre de notre
réseau et avec une connexion internet
fonctionne pour être capable
[Musique]
c'est fantastique 12 ans par mesure de
sécurité
tout à fait exact exactement il peut pas
dévoiler tous les détails c'est évident
tout à fait exactement on va vous poser
des questions embarrassantes vous avez
le droit pas répondre aujourd'hui
d'accord la première des plus
embarrassantes sait comment ils ont pu
se servir de votre numéro de téléphone
du centre d'appel antifraude du canada
où les canadiens vont appeler pour dire
je viens d'être vexé d'une fraude
comment est ce possible que les
fraudeurs face à utiliser depuis
plusieurs années les fraudeurs sont
réputés doit utiliser n'importe quelle
tactique pour être capable justement
rejoindre le plus grand nombre de
victimes potentielles et utiliser un
numéro de téléphone qui peut être connu
du public d'une institution ou d'un
organisme plus leur fournir davantage
que ça ajoute de la crédibilité à
l'appel et qui vont faire pour tenter de
convaincre les victimes de leur fournir
de l'argent si certains vendent
heureusement pour nous en conséquence
d'être lorsque le numéro de téléphone
est utilisée pour commettre une fraude
parce qu'à ce moment là ça peut rendre
travail un peu plus difficile
et comment expliquer une telle
vulnérabilité de l'appât du centre qui
est censé nous donner nous dire comment
nous protéger c'est pas juste nous qui a
été visée par un justement
la technologie que des projets utilisent
pour utiliser un numéro de téléphone il
ya d'autres agences gouvernementales qui
ont été touchés par par le fléau est la
chose qui est importante à se rappeler
c'est que à partir du centre antifraude
on fera pas d'appels d'externes vers des
gens où on fera pas d'appel qui vont
afficher ce numéro donc on va utiliser
d'autres façons pour rejoindre public si
on a besoin mais principalement numéro
sans frais et donc pour recevoir des
appels et non un dess donc à faire une
fête aussi des ajustements notre système
pour justement éviter que cela se
reproduise mais encore là des fraudeurs
ont quand même travaillé d'arrache-pied
à chaque fois qu'on va fournir une
réponse que ce soit nous ou que ce soit
par d'autres moyens disponibles via
l'industrie pour tenter de contourner ça
pour être capable de revenir les enfants
l'astuce ici elle est technique c'est à
dire que les fraudeurs passe pas par le
téléphone pour appeler ils passent par
leur ordinateur c'est ça souvent oui
c'est ça ils vont ils vont être dans une
région et x et vont utiliser la
technologie utilisant mais aussi débats
liés à l'informatique vous êtes capable
de masquer la date et l'identité
grillade où ils sont et à ce moment en
utilisant les moyens techniques d'alger
que du jaune yvon soit se présenter
comme si qu'ils utilisent un numéro deux
local pour justement faire apparaître
comme quoi qu'elle appelle vient d'ici
il n'est pas juste de minéraux qu'elles
utilisent et ça peut être carrément
d'autres numéros qui est inconnu aussi
mais lorsque ça le roi indique
l'indicatif 603 la plupart des gens
savent que c'est de la région d'ottawa
dont je t'avais pense que possiblement
ça soit le gouvernement qui les appelle
pour
la faveur d'un problème faire un suivi
par avoir une enquête qui est
complètement bidon
oui mais comment arrive-t-il à
subtiliser leurs numéros qui de
l'extérieur et de la faire apparaître
comme un numéro au canada et les
applications qui sont disponibles pour
justement permettre ce n'est un besoin
de faire des recherches internet
on est capable de trouver des outils qui
vont permettre justement de masse qui
l'a remplacé par m alors on est passé
les fêtes de fin d'année on est à
quelques jours et l'achalandage est
vraiment important il n'est pas rare
d'ailleurs je crois que c'est d'ailleurs
très très très visible en ce moment où
les clients sont sollicités par
différents magasins pour la vente
d'objets ou de cadeaux pour les enfants
et les familles quelles sont les
dispositions que vous avez prises pour
aiguiller les canadiens sur la meilleure
façon de détecter les faux appels
téléphoniques
c'est sûr que la meilleure façon c'est
d'en faire de la prévention c'est
l'élément clé où justement éduquer les
gens sur une nouvelle tendance à
l'entremise notre site web ou par les
médias sociaux parce que nous avons une
présence sur facebook et sur twitter
aussi à ce moment là on entend continuer
de distribuer le plus de messages
possible pour justement aider les gens à
être au courant des dernières tendances
mais aussi par l'entremise des
différends à remédier aux et on apprécie
beaucoup d'attention médiatique que cela
ozon sens que ça nous permet de
rejoindre un plus grand nombre de
personnes possible pour justement éviter
que ces personnes là quand dans le piège
des fraudes
je vais vous poser une question parce
qu'on est à une sur une plateforme
internationale et j'ai deux questions
pour vous la première c'est bien sûr
dans ce qui se passe qui arrive
présentement aux consommateurs canadiens
puis ou aux contribuables
on n'est pas dans un îlot ça doit se
passer ailleurs moi j'entends que paris
que ce qui se passe chez moi mais vous
devez vous parlez vous concerter entre
services policiers au niveau de la grc
puis d'interpol
ce que vous avez des choses en
préparation pour essayer pour pour
essayer mais pour essayer de
indiqué ça c'est ça pour que sa chute
internationaux que ce soit avec les
etats-unis la grande-bretagne
l'allemagne l'australie et ensemble
c'est certain que aussi on discute du
problème parce que souvent c'était ils
ont été ciblés de parts de quelque chose
s'il est à ce moment là aussi nous avons
des commentaires et avis à l'étranger
par l'organisme d'un programme de ces
liaisons car on a des agents de la grc
qui sont à des endroits stratégiques
dans le monde on a par exemple la wii on
and on a un agent de liaison la voie qui
nous permet d'avoir un point de contact
avec les autorités locales
alors là je te ra sergent je vous
interromps juste quelques secondes on
est en train de montrer des images de
centres d'appels de fraude en inde dans
lequel celui-ci news a fêté à tourner
des images de cacher c'était l'an
dernier je sois vous êtes au courant de
cette enquête par les médias oui oui
totalement et c'est justement ça permet
de montrer aux gens que le problème est
existant est réelle et que c'est pas
impossible que les gens reçoivent des
appels à l'occasion genre sur moi même
de ces gens d'appel n'ont heureusement
je suis capable de reconnaître et
d'ignorer l'appel ou simplement ne pas
tomber dans le panneau mais
malheureusement quand même beau on va
voir
et chaque fois qu'ils en connaissent de
perdus si le losc 1-2 lors de troubles
parce que chaque somme qui sont perdus
par les canadiens contribuent à
justement garder ses opérations en eaux
active
lorsqu'ils n'auront pas meetic tire mais
en ce moment là il n'y aura pas de
revenus pour subvenir aux besoins donc à
ce moment à l'eau ça vaut ils vont
devoir trouver d'autres mesures pour
être capable d'agrandir d'orfeuil là on
sait maintenant qu'au canada on va
empêcher crouesty et de contraindre les
appels qui arrive sur nos téléphones qui
provenaient de différents pays dont on a
parlé de l'inde mais mal et on
s'aperçoit que ça vient d'autres pays
est-ce que vous pensez que ça va faire
une différence est un peu tôt pour voir
si ça va on espère que justement ça va
aider à éviter ou au canadien et vive la
frustration de recevoir ce genre d'appel
parce que en discussion avec des
victimes ou des gens qui nous ont
signalé avoir été contacté par les
fraudeurs il peut voir recevoir parfois
quatre cinq six appels par jour donc ça
peut être quand même assez frustrant
parce qu'à chaque fois que le téléphone
sonne en est porté à vérifier qu'ils
nous appellent dit à ce moment-là
redécrocher téléphone pour savoir que
c'est un fraudeur kasri de deux séries
de l'argent donc on a l'impression qu'on
perd notre temps ce moment de ce qui a
été annoncé cette semaine c'est
seulement quelques forme de numéros de
téléphone qui peuvent être dix ont ciblé
par l'informatique de bell canada de
telus soutient martin implication mais
il ya autre chose qui s'en vient
peut-être l'an prochain à d'autres
mesures plus effet efficace peut-être
oui c'est sûr d'ici l'automne prochain
devra voir que les compagnies
téléphoniques elle nous avait pas laissé
assez de
de rendre disponible pour justement
éviter ou permettre aux gens de
reconnaître laquelle ou sinon le
processus va permettre de danse
d'authentifier la fed lucide et de
signaler ici ou d'alerter les gens pour
laisser savoir que si la psp après vous
c'est un travail doit aussi se faire de
concert avec les grandes entreprises
c'est la question que j'allais poser
justement c'est là que si l'appel sera
dans mon téléphone et je suis abonné par
exemple avec bell ou avec telus est ce
qu est ce que la personne qui fournit
service a pas une part de risque pour
responsabilité la dernière ils ont tout
à fait est ce qu'il ya comme des mesures
contraignantes vis-à-vis de ces
compagnies là qu'ils doivent absolument
nous protéger de ce type d'appels
frauduleux nous avec les partenaires et
les compagnies de téléphone c'est un
partenaire york ont par exemple lorsqu
on leur souhaite la pelle un signalement
d'un appel frauduleux au sens antique au
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec cette
information on prend le numéro de
téléphone une fois qu'on sait qui est le
fournisseur de ce numéro de téléphone
mais on ne refait pas justement quel
numéro de téléphone utilisés dans vivre
dans des fraudes leur a fourni une copie
du signalement qu'on est dessus aussi
pour leur permettre justement d'étudier
le droit vient de leur côté pouvoir
qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent faire pour
aider à diminuer l'ampleur du problème
ou carrément la règle donc je crois que
c'est un problème qui peut être juste se
résout par les services policiers mais
collectivement chacun une part de
responsabilité que ce soit les
compagnies téléphone ou sinon les
consommateurs aussi pour être capable
d'être vigilant parce que souvent la
tactique que les fraudes avons utilisé
pour être capable de convaincre les gens
que ils doivent envoyer de l'argent ils
vont utiliser un sentiment d'urgence que
ils nous envoient des actions immédiates
qui doivent être prises souvent ça peut
être un peu difficile à gagner mais de
prendre une pause et de se poser la
question est ce que la demande fait du
sens un close il est ce que je peux
faire des vérifications supplémentaires
pour justement m'éclairer sur la
question qui m'est posée où le problème
qui imite bambou on savoir si je devais
faire sur les vendeurs on a tous
probablement reçu cet appel non voilées
craint qu' ils vont se faire passer pour
des agences de revenus une scène de
vérification en allant vérifier notre
dos aussi avec l' agence de gavin ou en
contactant avec un agent de l' agence du
revenu par un numéro que l'on connaît et
non pas une europe et des fraudeurs de
riz pourrait souvent permettre aux gens
d'éviter la frustration d'avoir perdu
des sommes assez important parce qu'on
constate que des gens perdus mais il
2000 trouver de l'or même 25000 de
l'orgue face aux fraudeurs donc souvent
c'est d'argent plus ce qui est perdu à
jamais parce qu'une fois que l'argent
est envoyé aux fraudeurs c'est très
difficile de recevoir son argent
aussi quelle seulement quelques coups
que nous sommes capables de leur
retourner l'argent sergent j'aime bien
ce que vous avez dit pas ce que je pense
c'est un concert que j'aurais déjà
adopté il ya neuf ans lorsque j'ai été
victime d'une fraude comme ça bouge de
là vous le sunshine pull mais j'étais
tellement bête j'ai répondu j'ai donné
une information téléphone puis il ya eu
les résultats ensuite y en ait qui s'en
est suivi pas de détails évidemment mais
prendre faire une poste important mais
je vais vous poser la question suivante
et je pense et je pense que vous allez
peut-être confirmer ou infirmer je ne
sais pas mais il paraîtrait qu'une
nouvelle tactique des fraudeurs ce qui
vous appelle et puis vous vous dites je
vais vérifier vous raccrochez vous
décrocher le combiné
vous composez le bon numéro du ministère
mais le voleur le fraudeur il vous
attend il décroche il fait semblant que
des bons on répond au ministère est en
fait le même un autre fraudeur qui fait
partie de l'équipe qui répondit oui y'a
pas de problème effectivement on vous a
contacté siparex et grâce c'est tout
nouveau ça ça fait je dirais dernières
années même que ça se passe ce que les
fraudeurs utilisent si le lait des led
avec une recharge parce que c'est
surtout sur un téléphone avec encore une
ligne résidentielle ou que lorsqu'on
regarde pas c'est quand même un délai
avant que la communication soit souvent
se sert de salle disponible pour
permettre par exemple si on
on est dans une pièce de la maison et on
veut se déplacer un autre téléphone fixe
dans la maison pour être capable de
rester sur le même appel ce qui est
important pour les gens de reconnaître
c'est lorsqu'ils pensent qu'ils ont
régressé de vraiment attendre un peu
plus longtemps avant de raccrocher vite
vraiment entendre aussi le timbre sonore
que l'appel a vraiment été déconnecté et
quand même de se méfier aussi parce que
justement c'est une ruse que des
fraudeurs d'en exploiter qui semble
avoir aussi avoir une sorte un résultat
pour pour ea au détriment des gens
l'autre chose aussi que les jeunes que
vous avez mentionné que qui est
important parce que vous dites ok même
où ils me connaissent et qu'ils ont été
victimes de phobies je pensais lorsqu'on
était victime de fonds ne faut pas avoir
peur d'en parler justement pour éviter
que d'autres personnes
ce face à face à voir parce que souvent
c'est un ressenti siens qu'on rend
compte c'est que les gens ont été
victimes de fraude revenant paoli et le
fait d'en parler peut grandement aider
justement ces personnes a traversé
l'épreuve qu'ils ont subies par rapport
à la fraude mais aussi éviter que
d'autres gens tombent dans le même
panneau parce qu'à ce moment là pour
nous est au courant de qu'est ce qui se
passe va nous permettre aussi d'ajuster
nos messages de communication dans le
but d'éduquer les gens sur les dernières
tendances
ouais je dernière question pour vous je
couds de questions parce que je passe
mon temps au téléphone mais j'étais au
bureau il ya deux jours et tout le monde
était moins j'ai reçu un appel sur mon
cellulaire très peu de personnes
connaissent mon numéro en fait très peu
et bon c'est une jeune chinoise qui est
en train de me parler en chinois et
mais c'était pré enregistré c'est pas la
première fois que ça m'arrive même à la
maison je reçois de ces appels ce que
vous avez fait nuit j'en étais chargé en
chinois pendant mes congés lézarde
élargi noix ou qu'ils y arrivent au
québec au canada il ya un million de
chinois affluent au canada mais on
s'attend pas à recevoir des appels en
mandarin non qui c'est très similaire ou
s'appelle de lagence de michel haut de
forme d'extorsion c'est à dire que le
fraudeur avons utilisé une méthode où
ils vont instaurer un climat de peur
chez la victime et faire de montrer
qu'ils aient un sentiment d'urgence pour
que la personne envoie de l'argent que
rapidement possible pour éviter d'autres
termes la situation que vous me décrivez
c'est quelque chose qui se passe depuis
un peu plus d'un an déjà ou des messages
soient pré enregistrés ou automatisés en
chinois ou en mandarin sont faits de
façon aléatoire plus grand nombre de
numéros de téléphone possible dans
l'espoir justement d'avoir un
interlocuteur elle au bout de la vie
d'une personne ici qui comprend le
langage qui parlent la langue beta
personnes capables différends sur
certains que d'autres on comprend pas
mais c'est simple on accroche
mais même si on comprend la norme le
meilleur conseil ses temps forts de la
crise la façon d'être plus facile de se
détacher de cette situation qui peut
être carrément talent lorsque se
présente devant sur jean larroque vous
allez bientôt devoir raccrocher je vous
préviens mais on a une dernière question
pour vous ici en studio oui est-ce que
j'ai une question de sensibilisation
justement est-ce que vous avez pris
d'autres moyens comme les médias par
exemple pour atteindre davantage de
personnes au canada parce que les gens
ne savent pas toujours à quel saint se
vouer lorsqu'ils sont confrontés à ce
genre de difficultés c'est certain que
par l'entremise de notre site web
on en a en temps de mettre des mises à
jour fréquemment quoi c'est pour être
capable justement de sensibiliser les
gens sur les dernières tendances mais
aussi lorsque l'on fait on distribue
aussi avec un groupe de partenaires que
nous avons dans notre liste de
distribution à plus de 200 organismes ou
200 plus de 200 membres qui sont avec
nous des différentes agences ou de
différent
partenaires de l'industrie privée aussi
pour justement les a été un véhicule et
leur passage parce que c'est certain que
est un agence gouvernementale on a quand
même des moyens limités au niveau des
frais qu'on peut investir dans la
publicité donc on se fie beaucoup aussi
aux médias sociaux est aussi falloir
coming opportunités comme celles-ci pour
être capable de faire passer notre
message
une chose à se rappeler moyennant
période des fêtes il peut avoir certains
certaines des situations frauduleuses
mais aussi dans la nouvelle année
il ya un mois de mars qui s'en vient et
noah devance avec tous nos autres
partenaires dans la lutte contre la
fraude est dédié aux préventes à la
prévention de la faute donc à ce moment
alors on a aussi une augmentation du
nombre de messages clés ou être capable
justement de rejoindre plus grand nombre
possible de canadiens canadiennes pour d
éduquer sur les dernières tendances de
fraude et les dangers qui font qu'ils
peuvent se présenter face à eux dans
bull qui peuvent reconnaître quels sont
les enjeux pour justement éviter de
devenir une victime c'est pas toujours
évident quand on reçoit des appels de se
dire est ce que c'est on me demande une
petite information est ce que c'est à
donner ou pas c'est bien délicat merci
beaucoup sergent de nous avoir parlé
aujourd'hui nous montrer ce qui se passe
présentement pays ça m'a fait plaisir et
je serai tombeau et des gens capables de
la fête fait une faveur il faut
absolument lever ce cadre de votre de
votre ordinateur
c'est dangereux parfait alors c'est le
sergent guy paul larocque qui a pris de
gros risques pour nous parler
aujourd'hui
c'était sympathique
écoutez on est prêt pour le deuxième
tour de la grosse boule c'est pas fini
on apprend des choses allaient voir
aujourd'hui vous pensez vous avez bien
appris votre leçon avec le sergent c'est
du nouveau pour vous alors on va
découvrir
deuxième question de la grosse boule moi
si vous avez reçu un appel ces
hypothétiques mais ça pourrait se
produire
vous avez reçu un appel hier soir d'un
numéro inconnu qui débute par 7 3 8 ou 6
7 8 ou encore plus 41 d'accord que
devez-vous ne surtout pas faire
est-ce que c'est à alerter immédiatement
la police
est ce que ces bébés décrocher et
répondent poliment
tiens vous le prendrez poliment est ce
que c'est c'est rappeler en demandant la
raison de l'appel
ou est-ce que céder aucune de ces
réponses faire ou ne pas ne pas faire ce
que vous ne devez surtout pas faire eh
bien on ne devrait pas décrocher
répondre poliment
pourquoi vous étaient polis on attendait
a tenu à rappeler en demande a rappelé
en demandant la raison
on devrait pas faire ça on ne devrait
pas les rappeler pourquoi paquet vous
avez quelqu'un qui vous appelle alertées
immédiatement à la police qu'on devrait
pas faire décrocher
poliment aucune 2 n est pas prêt jusqu'à
s'est passé un numéro qui vient de 2,2
d'haïti ça excuse à we have it ça existe
que vous saviez tout ramène 50 cc c'est
ainsi qu'on ne ferait pas fait à la paix
la police immédiatement décrocher
répondre poliment à mais on est obligé
de décrocher parce que ça peut être un
appel important ça pourrait rappeler en
demandant la raison mais si on a manqué
l'appel rappelé en demande il faut bien
rappeler quand on a manqué un appel
quand même si c'est un numéro qu'on ne
connaît pas à mes programmes a rappelé
en demandant la raison mais moi
maintenant avec le cellulaire suivant
les sony je regarde donc d'où vient la
peine que et si je vois que ce niveau
que je ne connais pas ou qui vient
d'ailleurs vous rappelez pas je m'en
débarrasse donc je dirais il ne pas
faire c'est il m'est arrivé de rappeler
ce n'était pas un appel frauduleux donc
aucune de ces réponses une de ses
réponses il faut surtout pas ce qu'il
faut surtout pas faire c'est ok ok bon
vouloir de très bons et gérer ses mails
parce que dans le fond c'est rappeler en
demandant le voilà vous avez raison
c'est pourquoi aussi il faut pas faire
ça parce que voici ce qui se passe
les appels
vers numéro payant et c'est donc la
personne vous rappeler est la personne
physique vous êtes monsieur qui s'éteint
sites de pornographie c'est un super
pote de roscor pour les ja mais
récemment j'ai rappelé ouais c'était
quelqu'un qui m'appelait justement de
l'international parce que nous qui
venons d'ailleurs on a des familles
ailleurs aussitôt une fin c'est bien
quand même décor de votre pays déjà qui
les appelle habituellement
oui mais on peut m'appeler du cameroun
ça peut être un appel qui vient je sais
pas moi de l'europe en amérique ou des
états unis
voici ce qui se passe vous appeler et
dès que vous appelez ça y est vous êtes
sur la minute et vous qu'on vous charge
de la mildt vous le savez pas ça peut
être un dollar américain vous le savez
pas il s'abstient et ça coûte cher et on
dit oui non attends dijon va vérifier
pourquoi quand vous aurez appliquer
cette fois que c'était le sait ou non y
en a je compte raisonnable voilà bien
alors qui consiste à fait à vous faire
jouer un petit jeu wii un gros lots à
gagner
mais reste eh oui on joue un peu de
musique qui est qui est un musicien
associé avec la couleur pourpre vous
allez répondre dit pimpant ou un car oui
prize et là vous répondez plus est si on
vous dit félicitations vous avez
première bonne réponse très stable et
nous avons la deuxième question pour
gros gros lots à gagner et sterling
auprès de vos informations doit avoir un
peu de prison et vous montrions pour la
prendre des leçons le cabinet répondu
vous avez tous répondu le mois j'avais
répondu je ne sais quoi s'était déjà
ajouté j'ai chargé changes avait changé
parce que changer parce que je me suis
mise à spéculer à analyser et puis on
exclut le bon sens veut que quand donc
on fait le bilan il ya 70 boules à faire
jusqu'à maintenant combien la verdure
vous avez perdu 20 je n'ai pas perdu
dont vous êtes encore 70 si vous en
reste 50 ans on commence à sand amitié
boué nom n'a pas perdu c'est vrai vous
avez raison vous êtes à 80 80 oui vous
êtes à 500
en fait j'ai changé changer de rythme
certains des fans alors j'ai dû passer
un sapin bull qui reste dans ma poche
c'est de la fraude
bon écoute et non j'ai une petite vidéo
à vous montrer c'est pour en savoir plus
sur le sujet traité aujourd'hui vous
avez tous écrit là-dessus
allez vous connaître vous reconnaître
sur le sait la vidéo de 0,6 j'appelle ça
c'était un beau titre pour en savoir
plus ah oui on entre ça et je pense
qu'on a la mine 8 aujourd'hui sur notre
site web tellement ça vous intéresse
comme sujet on défile rapidement c'est
pas c'est pas dans le détail qu'on veut
se perdent aujourd'hui oui ça tourne
autour d'un autre thématique du jour
ouais c'est ça qui est si je défile un
peu plus rapidement vers le bas voilà ce
que ça donne
on comprend qu'il ait donné tout ça
c'est sur la page web de sécurité je
pense que c'est vous la ceco minul avec
masque et oui c'est de vous le savez
l'arctique écrit en 2013 je crois
effectivement ok on est prêt la dernière
question vous êtes en bonne position
tous à 80 beau symbole maintenant 50 ans
jeudi
ouais je ne la question oui j'ai
toujours voulu c'est pas pire c'est
comme on dit à 3e tour 50 boules à
perdre voici la question à l'affût pour
tout le monde et c'est très court allez
voir sur ce selon le centre antifraude
du canada sur sa victime
combien portes de plaintes combien là
vous vraiment on met portes de plaintes
est ce que ces dix canadiens sur 100 qui
sont victimes qui portent plainte ou dix
victimes sur 100 canadiens qui portent
plainte ou est-ce que c'est 20 b parce
que la bonne réponse c'est 40 sur ça ou
encore est-ce que c'est le fameux aucune
de ces bonnes réponses
est-ce qu'il l'a dit tantôt mais il a
failli dire genou maintenant il l'a dit
à très peu de personnel c'est ce qu'il a
dit ouais alors c'est très peu est-ce
que c'est proche de 10 enfin les très
peu vain
c'est possible sinon bah c'est un sur
cinq seulement ses traits moi je
conserve sa très peu très peu disque il
ya eu 20 2001 et en 2006 en 2017
22000 et on dit que très peu de
canadiens se sont plaints doumen y en
avait 20 2010 est ce que la bonne
réponse sur combien je déplace je
n'avais pas quoi 750 vous 800000 quelque
chose comme ça il ya eu au total 22 min
21 plaintes au total
d'accord mais on dit que c'est une
infime proportion ou une faible
proportion ou une charge terrible c'est
un nombre tout m oui disent ils un film
ce serait la bonne réponse selon une
alice maryse aubin je tiens des rejets
allen est clair le a aussi on affiche la
bonne réponse surtout vous allez voir
c'est comme aller au casino
aucune l'abonné bce s'est pas beaucoup
cinq points c'est sûr qu'à 10% n'était
pas si c'était pas si loin de voiliers 5
peut-être qu'ils se disent que la cause
est perdue à l'avance mois notamment
parce que les gens en moins dans mon
post je suis dessus c'est vraiment bête
de ma part vraiment pas très intelligent
pour ie pas me vanter mais ça fait
tellement longtemps que ces produits non
j'ai rien perdu si l'on voit les et la
banque a tout de suite allé je pense
qu'on est peut-être un peu mieux
protégés projet anti par les banques
oui je pense que les gens ce qui se
passe au même moment que les valeurs
venait de se manifester au téléphone
mais c'est pas rassurant parce que je
sais où je vais adresser à la base
j'étais passé à m'adresser à la banque
le jt comme quand on est nerveux l'on
sait plus long du monde u est ce que
c'est vraiment là bas en fait il avait
piqué votre numéro de carte de crédit ou
exacte et voulait une confirmation des
trois derniers chiffres m'ont cassé le
28 32 28 32
bon j'ai changé informations
confidentielles écoutez il ya toujours
une part à part d'aération mais dans le
fond cela résister mois écoutez j'ai
l'image de la semaine pour vous barque
et je sens que ça a quelque chose à voir
avec noël je réponds seulement de leur
charmant vous devez deviner quelle est
l'image de semaine bon ok ça a à voir
avec le vol de cadeaux non pas les vols
de cadeaux dans la perle maël et le fait
que peut-être un ministre à repasser
petit message pour le père noël
le ministre garde jean rien entendu à ce
sujet là donc là d'image la main avec
noël ouais c'est un petit rapport avec
noël beau petit rapport est ce que ça se
passe au canada
oui oui ça sent une âme au pôle nord non
non mais je il ya un élément de
nordicité divergent d'un nordicité
l'hiver oui absolument
une partisane où il ya de la neige là
dedans certainement certainement que de
la neige le temps où l'on s'est produit
à la hauteur du ballon à poser plus de
questions à ce que ces minéral végétal
ou automatique alors automatique non
automatique entre effroi il est connu au
canada où le fait que l est pas toujours
ramassé ou bien ça se mange à vous aider
à s'ajuster neil c'est presque une bûche
de noël tient dans comme vous visez si
proche de l'arrivée ça se mange ça se
mange mais c'est tellement petit que je
sais nous a beau l'avoir l'élève de
l'avoir continue à avoir faim si vous
deviez le manger
oui en bêlant franchement adepte
racontez là je savais pas c'est la
première fois que vous y arrivez pas là
on est perdu on aurait besoin de se
traîner rails
c'est ça c'est trop cher qu'une maison
une maison est ce que c'est un dessert
c'est un dessert c'est que c'est la
fable avec une maison me c'est un site
apparentés aux biscuits bien sûr bien
sûr mais oui un petit pas des pis à bas
mais voyez comme vous êtes bon on va
voilà petitpas dps miniature le plus
petit au monde fait partie
c'est le sens de l'humour aux copies
électroniques d'université mcmaster de
hamilton qui s'est fait avec du pain
d'épicés mais attendez on va faire un
zoom salaires impayés lectronique les
trucs
ouais ouais ça ressemble un petit peu
dynamique de l'intelligence artificielle
c'est tout six vous allez voir à quel
point ces petits là vous voyez un
bonhomme de neige comme il la neige
d'accord et vous allez voir c'est plus
loin vous êtes allé chercher loin
oui je sais mais c'est moi qui me
semblait des affaires d'électronique ça
me passionne je veux qu'à des affaires
d'électronique à noël voici on va
regarder maintenant un cheveu humain
à côté de cette création est envahie où
le bonhomme de neige la petite maison
cachée là au fond de la forêt et votre
cheveu maryse 28 10 ch on va manquer oui
ça va
pétri ça me rappelle vraiment j -cl et
20 mille fois plus petit qu'une maison
en pain d'épicés alors comment ils ont
fait pour écrire sur un truc aussi petit
ça c'est faux la za pourquoi j'ai aucune
idée comment les appeler
c'est à elle a regardé la porte pour
ceux qui veulent trouver l'information
additionnelle puisque c'est important de
coups poursuit cette soirée là ceci dans
l'associé le centre canadien de
microscopie électronique de l'université
mcmaster et l'homme qui a créé ça
s'appelle travis qu'à sa grande et
travis de la grande maison
je trouve ça très joli comme non et
comment vous la résumer sur le site de
cbc news madame ouais mais caché quelque
part c'est une abside j'espère que c'est
pas le cadeau qu'il faisait à sa
conjointe ou à quelqu'un de la famille
je serai pas le prix que ça coûte plus
cher car c'est dans l'avenir un jose
heures sur des camions miniatures
c'est bon pour quand on avait dans un
pays a pas d'espacé au canada notamment
l'espace on peut mettre une maison des
pistes dans sa cour arrière ya pas de
problème mais quand on habite sur pluton
c'est une autre histoire voilà pas de
commentaire non mais plutôt nier sont
radioactives quand on les critique
voilà merci beaucoup maryse merci ce fut
un plaisir de voir conserver vos boules
cette semaine merci hélas et lorsqu on
va se revoir et qu'on reverra nos
auditeurs ou téléspectateurs
cette année ce sera quelle date je ne
sais pas quoi le 10 et le 10 janvier les
10 20 20
[Musique]